yeah I'm okay with it too I mean I've
just found that the relationships that I
have um
pursued and the people that I'm like
really interested in are really
open-minded and really not judgmental
and don't um yeah and I mean so it
really hasn't I don't know maybe I'm
delusional but it hasn't affected me
negatively
um but I also came into this like way
before it was like the [__] cool
thing to do like I started doing only
fans like it was like like 2016 and 17.
so I you know it was a lot more
difficult for me in the beginning when
people were like what now people you
know now that they feel like it's
actually become more accepted so maybe
for me I'm just used to more harsher
judgment and it feels less less so
all right rock and roll okay so I got
some specific questions for each of you
individually so I have a note here from
Kiana uh you had an interesting first
date anecdote something with a guy with
a phone
yeah so I went on when I first fully got
into
um
porn I was still or no I had moved here
I had moved back so I'm originally from
LA but I had moved back to LA and that's
when like
one of the First videos I did was one of
the biggest videos I did it was the
Bangbus video which gets oh everyone
knows what the bank bus is that was my
first video I ever filmed because what's
that I don't know what that is yeah it's
a blossom they Bang Yeah so you pretty
much have sex in a bus
um but it's like very notorious and like
is it the bus or more of a van it's a
it's a van it's a van it's
very uncomfortable to film in is it just
you and one other person or is there
like every every person yeah so it's you
the person uh you're filming with and
then the person that's filming and the
person that's driving okay so your first
date go ahead so the first day I went on
he it was I was like very new in the
industry so I really didn't think that
people knew me
um so I
told him he told me that he like didn't
watch porn he wasn't in to any of it I
told him that I did only fans and then
literally in the middle I was like about
to hook up with this person and like he
opened his phone and his phone searched
history was looked up and it was just
Kiana kamani porn and it was like 10
search histories of my name
I was very scared you were scared yeah I
mean I was alone with this person I was
terrified because he swore up and down
he didn't know me and like the whole
date was it was great until I literally
my because I told him my real name
he found me it was like my Instagram
that is like my personal Instagram and
so I really like didn't think that he
knew me at all and then it was yes so
you mentioned it on the date though you
you mentioned it I told him I did only
fans but like I looked prior to meeting
him
wait you saw the time stamps and it was
like it was like before like he's been
doing research because it's like you
know when it says today and then like
yesterday when in your search history
wait why were you how much time do you
have to leave he opened his phone in
front of me yeah and I saw my name from
the side of my eye and I was like what
is that oh
[Music]
I'm not a man of God but I'll pray for
you all
thank you for praying thank you thank
you Victor for praying appreciate it I
don't know if you're just tuning I don't
know if you're just tuning in but it's
been an absolute [__] show Victor uh
thank you I appreciate it okay not not
just like for technical reasons not okay
um so okay you're about to hook up with
the dude you see on his phone he was
Googling your Bangbus video yeah and it
was like black was your blocked video
also I I'm
black it's just it's I've only filmed
with Bang Bros team ski team ski team
ski okay they asked me to never mind I
need
what's like the most like
ear what's what's the term for uh bad
repute
like the just most [__] company that you
I don't know if you want to blast them
but
um
vixen's good is that like the one with
the I think I don't know okay
I'm exposing myself right now
[Music]
um I honestly think it does depend like
the I don't know if it's the CEO or the
CFO of bangbros is a piece of [__]
um the way that they run their companies
uh not the best
um but team ski has definitely asked me
things that I have not been the most
um okay with like they'll ask me to film
okay fair enough okay but so you see the
[__] on your phone
on his on his phone
yeah and I was like let me see I was
like are you looking me up I asked him
at first and then he was like no no it's
not you and I was like I literally just
saw like my name my poor name pop up and
it I scrolled through and it was like
days of history of him looking my name
but did it start
[Laughter]
did it start from when you matched with
them
I didn't look that far back because
we've been talking on and off for a
while for a while okay but so you see it
then what happens
I
I ran out of it you're right you did I
ran you didn't matter
I I ran out of there as fast as I
possibly could because listen I I have
dated people that have looked me up
like and but they're open with the fact
of yes I've watched your videos and I'm
I'm fine with it I don't mind it but if
you're hiding that you don't know who I
am and it's days of search history
[Music]
okay so that's uh Good Times
um all right
good to know good to know because I mean
you know maybe he's seen listen I love
details like I love when guys have
watched my videos like I think it's like
the guy that I'm kind of talking to
right now has like after we started
talking the guy who has you knocked up
correct he hasn't FYI she's pregnant by
the way thanks just reminding you guys
yeah my uh Baby Daddy has watched my
videos and like I don't my like he's he
watches your videos he's watched my
videos
he's not the guy you're [__] on
camera right but the thing is is the
videos are very very fake and they're
very not me at all like the videos that
I filmed Johnny Sins
I've Never filmed with him I was
supposed to but I didn't okay
um so the videos that I have filmed is
very very fake and it's not me and like
you can even hear it and but it's you
getting [__] yeah but it's still my
moans are fake it's not like I I see sex
very differently from on set and like my
personal life like my personal life is I
see it as a soul tie connection it's
very intimate it's very personal it's
who I am and on set I turn into Kiana
kumani actress yeah
like a Persona type thing how can you
hold those two at the same time I'm
genuinely curious it messed me up very
bad badly and that's why I don't do
mainstream videos anymore because for me
right now I still will film but I would
like to film for my only fans with my
partner or who I'm with
um because I am I see sex very
differently now and I
want to have that Soul tie and that
genuine connection with the person that
I am sleeping with because it it does it
does mess with your head a lot like the
industry definitely does whether people
want to admit it or not
um okay but in any case your current guy
who
he watches videos of you getting [__]
by other guys he's watched them like
once or twice see for me like as a dude
like I would no there's no way I'm
looking at the video of my girl getting
[__] by another dude I feel like it's
he was very aware of what I did teach
their own teach their own did he know
oh yeah for sure it was one of the first
things I said to him when he walked
outside oh you guys know
oh
three of us all lived together yeah yeah
all right did science okay it's an
interesting house yeah it's a pretty fun
house all right I got a question for you
um so your your corn name is Kiana Kiana
kumani
I get it um that's where the name yeah
question would you be down to um this is
a whatever exclusive
do any porn stars ever like uh have a
middle initial
no do you think you could like put
another K in there
see the thing is is my real name my real
name is spelled
um my real name is with the K as so
Kiana is my real name but I just spell
it differently so it's K and then my
last name also starts with a K okay yeah
got it okay I have some more notes Here
for for some of you guys okay so CJ
photo booth X
um what is Taurus Rising oh
into the mic quiz
um I
um ology are you Taurus I am not a
tourist son
just show of hands who here believes in
astrology kind
shove hands all right that's just
[__] okay
um you're a dancer stripper
okay we already we already figured that
out um are you wearing your cross
necklace by the way
no okay
all right
is it a special cross necklace
he texted in the group chat before we
started the podcast she was like I
literally just took off my cross
cross necklace
who said that well I I reviewed your
guys's Instagrams before and so he was
looking for that I noticed that I wear
it a lot and I saw like every photo
you're wearing a cross thing and I'm
like okay damn that's hilarious because
she mentioned that to us she mentioned
it in the group chat oh yeah go get it
put it on
so I can roast you for it
all right we have uh Elle Marie baby
hello
um
actually wait I'm coming wait you say in
your profile something about the law of
attraction what what are you talking
about
um The Law of Attraction just like
meaning that I think I said like
something along the lines of like the
law of attraction is a powerful thing is
that what I said I'm about I don't know
anyway so you believe in the Law of
Attraction yeah I believe you attract
what you put out and I believe in Good
Karma and Bad Karma and I think that if
you like if you go if you go to people
and you speak that and you speak to them
and treat them with kindness and respect
and dignity despite disagreements or
having difference of opinion then that
that good karma comes back to you
eventually and that's important so like
if I attract if I put that out then I
attract that and that's That's the Law
of Attraction that's what I think at
least okay
I feel like when people say the Law of
Attraction this is what I hear I hear I
want to just do nothing and have
everything come to me and just be like
yeah just be like you know polite to
people and yeah no I mean I definitely I
definitely don't think of it in that
sense I don't think that I'm just like
doing nothing like I think that
I think that being kind to others is
like how much charity work have you done
last month
no I'm just saying I'm like we need
metrics to like quantify
um I mean charity work like you mean
like like going in like like
um what the [__] is the word I'm drawing
a boy I'm not I'm not saying I'm not
saying this like like I expect that
you've done charity work this month it's
just like we'll say oh I think being
nice and being kind and whenever we like
quantify it if there's never anything
that we can quantify it yeah okay well I
just mean in the sense of like
a lot of people go throughout their day
just being disrespectful and ignorant
and mean to other people for absolutely
no [__] reason so to me I think that
that I think that that way of life is
not going to get those people very far
so I don't know and all right good times
okay Law of Attraction okay um so really
quick I want to go back to of so just
show of hands again who here has an of
or had in the of
one two three four
three four okay and then not her okay uh
if you guys are comfortable sharing how
much you guys make on of
um we'll start with you go ahead I just
started making about 20 to 30 000 a
month
okay
I'm not comfortable sharing six figures
I'm not comfortable sharing seven
figures okay fair enough what about you
I don't know I don't ever use it oh
right you're kind of not really using it
what about uh dancing how much do you
make per night oh gosh that's average
that's a loaded question
um it
could be really anything I've had nights
where I've taken home five grand I've
had nights where I've taken home nothing
and most of her dancing was in Ohio in a
small town as well Columbus no Columbus
isn't a small town well we've oh we also
danced in Dayton so Dayton is smaller
yeah okay
can I have a question about dancing
um would you say that you get make more
from talking to the guys or from dancing
tonight please would you say you make
more from talking to guys and kind of
having more of like an intimate
conversation or more of an intimate
dance
I say talking for sure 100 I'd say a bad
stripper I make about 70 000.
go ahead I make about 70 000 a month all
right and then Zoe when you were active
how much uh were you making what
stripping or uh yeah break it down
between stripping and though oh man when
I was stripping I was like 22 I'm 27 now
so I mean honestly literally the most
money I made by luck was three grand
because I I hate I just I was a great
dancer but talking wise I cannot stroke
a man's ego that easy and it I can't
stand it but of I make about five
figures a month five five figures a
month mid low high mid mid okay
[Laughter]
um so when I danced I did travel a lot I
went to different countries the most are
different not different countries
different states and the most I made
when I was when I was in New York and
that was like literally a 20K night that
was an insane full day Excursion from
Dancing Yeah from dancing alone okay
um and then the but like I would average
at like Ohio like most uh most was about
five case but damn shocked 70k wow
yeah I know I know baby hold on just a
second as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible